the gyro can experience it's so weird
how much more survival how much of our
like caveman [ __ ] is still there and how
much of the survival stuff like I've
been doing listening to a lot of therapy
podcasts or just one called the adult
chair it's this woman Michelle Chalfont
and she's just it's all about dealing
like with your inner child and then all
and all of your instincts she was like
the adolescent chair in the adult chair
and your adolescent chair is all of your
ego and your emotions in your fight
fight or flight like all of that the
stuff that you do the procrastination
whatever is your problem like why is
that happening there's something that's
coming from either your child chair or
something from your childhood or things
like socially when you have social
anxiety and panic attacks and stuff so
much of it could be just back from in
the days if you were excommunicated from
your tribe like you would die yes if we
were a part of the club you would
[ __ ] die
and that that that's the reason why
people are afraid of public speaking is
that when you were speaking in front of
a group you were trying to save your
life you were trying to plead your case
mm-hmm for the most part unless you were
the leader of the tribe most of the
people were just trying to say please I
didn't know and don't kill me is that
how you feel walking around me no but
the comedies are people are like no
merciful king no you know how I feel
walking around I feel like they don't
it's like they don't have anybody house
but is the way to put it when you are
listening to someone all the time that
person's in your ear the person becomes
like a weird part of your life and then
you meet them you're like wow this is
crazy that you're right here I've
experienced that when I first met
Anthony Bourdain I was worried about
yeah I believe you're right here this is
so weird I see you and I've gotten used
to that over time but still it's strange
when I meet famous people yeah you know
what I mean and it's even weirder when I
mean famous people and they know me and
what yeah yeah become famous people
together like I think I've seen that
before at [ __ ] when two famous people
just see and then you're just arty
you're already in this weird Club of
famous people mm-hmm
it's strange automatically a famous
people club well it's it's not a normal
state and it's not I mean people that
are that enjoy the podcast it becomes a
part of their life and maybe it benefits
them and maybe they start getting
motivated and cleaning up their life and
start being healthier and exercising and
eating better and then then it becomes
just like almost like a religion yeah
but because it becomes the thing that
you think of you know in terms of like
how to benefit your life how to live in
a positive way you think about the
things you learned on the podcast almost
like you would look at a religious
doctrine yeah you look at the the
teachings of Christ you know you look at
the teachings of Moses or you look at
like oh what Rhonda Patrick said right
yes oh well you know what Graham Hunt
Hancock was talking your voices like in
their head you're like a on hired coach
well the laminate of that it's and it's
also represents my own quest to try to
figure out my own life and to do it
publicly and explain what I've learned
and how I failed yeah what I've gotten
better at it helps other people when you
hear that because you all cam alone like
I'm because people think that it's like
your life is in order right now that
it's always been like that so I think it
really helps people to hear like oh I
used to be a [ __ ] loser yeah and I
did and I can be scared to talk to bank
tellers and it was true yeah it has to
be weirded out socially I was very
strange
[Applause]